Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Süngücü.
Ich bin einstin hier und möchte gerne mit Ihnen eine Aufnahme geschickt werden.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir.
Ja, gut. Aber selbst wenn es sich einmal ein paar Taillons von Ihnen herdacht.
Wie heißt er?
Jetzt haben wir ein Verbindungsproblem.
Jetzt höre ich Sie wieder. Sie waren zwischendurch weg.
Ich konnte Sie auch nicht hören.
Okay, ich sehe wie immer.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Willi Jeger.
Willi Jeger.
Können Sie mir Ihre Poll und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, Willi, W, I, W, L, I, der Nennername.
Und Jeger, J, A, Umlaut, G, E, R.
Hör Jeger. Ja, richtig.
Hör Jeger, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Und wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,74, steht in meinem Pass zumindest.
Und ich wiege noch so 75 Kilo.
Okay, mal kurz.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen haben?
Ja, wissen Sie, mir geht es eigentlich schlecht in letzter Zeit.
Und ich habe vor allen Dingen so komische Schmerzen beim Schlucken.
Und das wird eigentlich immer schlimmer.
Am Anfang war das so, dass ich nur so dachte,
ja, wenn ich, ich habe vielleicht nicht gut gekaut
oder müsste mehr zum Essen trinken, damit das besser runterrutscht.
Aber jetzt wird es eigentlich immer mehr,
dass das richtig weh tut.
Und das ist, so als ob ich nicht gut gekaut ist.
Das tut dann hier so, ich hier so oben in der Brust,
als ob das nicht weiterrutschen will.
Ja, der tut mir das weh.
Und ich habe dann so das Gefühl,
dass ich wie so ein Kloster sitzen habe.
Ja.
Und wie gesagt, am Anfang war das nur beim Essen.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, Mensch, Willi, du musst besser kauen.
Und besser, ne?
Und dann, ja, jetzt ist es aber auch schon, wenn ich etwas trinke.
Also selbst wenn ich nur ein Schluck Wasser trinke,
habe ich das Gefühl, ich kriege das gar nicht so richtig durch den Hals.
Und das ist natürlich ein bisschen blödes Gefühl.
Und dazu kommt, ja, ich fühle mich eigentlich so ein bisschen schlapp.
Ich bin nicht so richtig leistungsfähig.
Ich bin verwittet und sorge immer noch für meine Kinder.
Die sind zwar jetzt schon relativ groß,
aber brauchen mich irgendwie doch.
Zurzeit komme ich mit der Arbeit und mit der Familie,
mit den ganzen Aufgaben nicht mehr zu Recht.
Ich habe mich verstanden wegen der Verbindung zu Problemen.
Ah, okay, ja.
Also ich fühle mich meinen Aufgaben in der Familie
und bei der Arbeit überhaupt nicht mehr gewachsen.
Das strengt mich alles furchtbar an.
Und ja, ich fühle mich einfach schlapp.
Danke, Herr Versteher.
Und weitermachen wir, wie war das?
Ja, das ist eigentlich seit einigen Wochen.
Am Anfang, wie gesagt, das ist bestimmt schon eine ganze Weile her,
vielleicht schon zwei Monate, dass ich das gemerkt habe,
so da ist so dieses Schluckproblem.
Aber jetzt wird es eben eigentlich schlimmer.
Und seit drei Wochen wird es eben richtig krass,
dass ich das merke.
Okay.
Also Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Schluckprobleme haben.
Also ich würde gerne wissen,
diese Schluckprobleme,
ist es beim Flüssigkeit oder beim Festernahrungs?
Am Anfang nur bei Festernahrung
und jetzt eben auch schon bei Flüssigkeit.
Das beunruhigt mich so.
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Luftnot habe ich nicht, nein.
Also manchmal muss ich so ein bisschen husten.
Ja, aber so luftnötig bin ich nicht.
Okay, seit wann habe wir so?
Ach ja, man hustet ja immer mal so ein bisschen.
Ich habe das jetzt so auf den Herbst geschoben,
weil es ein bisschen kälter geworden ist.
Es hat nochmal so ein bisschen husten.
Aber das so husten muss ich schon, ja.
Haben Sie heilschmerzen?
Heilschmerzen, in dem Sinne eigentlich nicht.
Manchmal muss ich so ein bisschen aufstoßen,
dass da so ein bisschen was Saueres hochkommt.
Haben Sie Sortspillern?
Minimal, ja.
Also richtig doll ist so, brenn nicht,
aber so ein bisschen, das ist so etwas, ja doch schon.
Fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht, nein.
Also, haben Sie Übelkeit oder ein Berecher?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht.
Aber manchmal fühle ich mich so,
als ob ich mich gleich übergeben muss.
Kennen Sie, dass kurz bevor man sich übergeben muss,
hat man so ganz viel Spucke im Mund.
Dass da sich so ganz viel Speichel sammelt.
Und das habe ich auch, aber ich, also das ist nicht verbunden
mit der Übelkeit und diesem Gefühl,
ich muss mich dann nicht übergeben.
Aber ich habe ganz viel Speichel.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Aber Sie sind noch nie sich übergeben?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr apäzit?
Oh, in letzter Zeit habe ich gar keinen apäzit.
Mir schmeckt es eigentlich überhaupt nicht.
Und ich glaube, ich habe auch ziemlich abgenommen.
Okay, wie viel Kilogramm haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, ich meine, ich hätte immer so 78 kg gewogen.
Den habe ich neulich mal gewogen
und jetzt wiege ich nur noch 75 kg.
Okay, in Bergheilsweizlohn haben Sie 80 kg abgenommen?
Boah, wie lange ist das?
Vielleicht ein Monat?
Wie sicher nicht ständig?
Seit einem Monat?
Okay, seit einem Monat.
Und ist das nicht absichtlich?
Nein, also mir schmeckt es halt nicht.
Also das merke ich schon, dass ich keinen apäzit habe
und eben auch, dass ich mich so schlapp fühle.
Okay, weiß ich.
Und haben Sie nachts Schweizer oder Schütze abgerostet?
Nein, nachts schwitze ich eigentlich nicht.
Nein, und Schüttelfrost, nee, das hat man ja so,
wenn man Fieber hat, das habe ich aber nicht.
Okay, okay, da leiden wir an Klonischeerkrankungen
und wenn ich jetzt nur so Beispiel Bluthoff zurück
oder Zuckerkrankheiten.
Ja, also ich habe schon seit 15 Jahren
habe ich eine Zuckerkrankheit
und ja, das war vor zwei Wochen auch,
da waren die Werte mal so ein bisschen durcheinander,
aber eigentlich bin ich da ganz zuverlässig eingestellt.
Ich nehme da immer Ikandra, da nehme ich eine morgens
und eine abends und damit ist es eigentlich
bisher immer ganz stabil gewesen.
Ich nehme da eine Morgenswene, ich kann es doch.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, versteht ihr da drauf?
Da steht irgendwas mit 50 drauf.
Okay, und haben Sie eine Werteerkrankung?
Ja, also der Arzt hat mal gesagt,
ich hätte so ein bisschen Herzrhythmusstörungen
oder dass das so leicht stolpert, das Herz
und dann hat er mir auch Marco Mar verschrieben,
das war mir aber eigentlich zu kompliziert mit dem Einnehmen.
Da musste man ja dann immer den Wert bestimmen
und da habe ich ihn gefragt, ob das wichtig ist,
ob man das nicht auch weglassen kann.
Dann hat er gesagt, na ja, so doll sind die Herzrhythmusstörungen nicht.
Das war vielleicht einmalig.
Also zurzeit nehme ich da nichts ein.
Okay, morgens?
Nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme gar nichts ein.
Nehmen Sie keine Marco Mar ein, ja?
Nein, das war mir zu kompliziert, wissen Sie?
Okay.
Ihr Arzt empfält Ihnen, aber...
Ja, der hat das mal empfohlen, weil er das gesagt hat
und dann habe ich gesagt, ist das denn wirklich so schlimm,
dass man das unbedingt machen muss
und dann war es eigentlich auch wieder ein bisschen besser,
dass das beim EKG gar nicht so schlecht war,
aber vielleicht war das auch nur im Rahmen von irgendeiner Erkrankung,
dass das mal ein bisschen aus dem Takt war.
Okay, also das kann noch ein wichtiges sein.
Wir können nach unserer Gespräche nochmal kontrollieren,
ihre Herz, und danach können wir entscheiden.
Aber ich hatte jetzt in letzter Zeit nicht das Gefühl,
dass mir mein Herzprobleme macht.
Okay, verstehe.
Und nehmen Sie andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich eigentlich gar nichts.
Okay.
Sind Sie jegeneitwas allergisch?
Also ich habe eine...
Ja, ich habe eine Allergie, ich darf kein Diplof hinachnehmen.
Und was ich auch habe, also wenn die Gräser blühen,
dann habe ich ein bisschen Probleme, so Gräserpollen
und dann habe ich halt so tränende Augen
und die Nase läuft und da muss ich immer ein bisschen aufpassen.
Und wie reagieren Sie auf Diplof hinach?
Ja, da habe ich einen Ausschlag bekommen.
Herr Jaeger, wo bin Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, also ich hatte mal eine kleine Operation.
Und zwar hatte ich am Ellenbogen, auf der linken Seite,
so ein Schleimbeutel und den hat man entfernt.
Aber das war ein kleiner ambulanter Eingriff.
Da musste ich gar nicht in Krankenhaus bleiben.
Also das war schnell vorbei.
Okay, wann war das?
Oh, das ist so zwölf Jahre her, da hat meine Frau noch gelebt.
Ja, doch, da war das.
Okay.
Und wie geht es Ihnen?
Ja, also so ganz kann ich es eigentlich nicht lassen.
Ich rauch schon eigentlich immer noch ein Päckchen am Tag.
Und zwei zwanzig?
Ja, seit ich zwanzig bin.
Und vorher haben Sie probiert, mit seinem Rauch um aufzuhören, oder?
Ja, ich habe auch mal ein bisschen mehr geraucht.
Das war mal mehr als ein Päckchen am Tag.
Und dann habe ich mal versucht, das ein bisschen einzuschränken.
Aber ja, so ganz ohne ich schaffe ich das nicht.
Okay, wann Sie wollen, mit seinem Rauch um aufzuhören,
haben wir in Krankenhaus gar nicht so zu viel.
Und können wir Sie gerne unterstimmen?
Ja, aber ich glaube, ich habe ja mehrere andere Probleme.
Okay.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so, ich trink abends nach Feierabend, trinke ich so zwei Bier
und am Wochenende trinke ich auch mal Schnaps,
aber also nicht viel Alkohol.
Aber in letzter Zeit hat mir das auch nicht so gut geschmeckt.
Wissen Sie, wenn das beim Runterschlucken alles wehtut,
dann schmeckt er mochte Schnaps nicht.
Okay, das ist ja dann.
Und mein Erfolg in der Frage, bitte nehme ich wenig Speise an mich.
Das ist so eine Frage, nehme ich wie Droge?
Ob ich Drogen nehme?
Nein, also Drogen nehme ich wirklich nicht.
Okay, gut.
Und hör, ja, da war ich die Frage, ob Leben jeder Alk sei noch?
Nein, nein, meine Mutter ist gestorben da, die war Mitte Ende 70,
weiß gar nicht genau, so 76 oder so, die hatte Darmkrebs.
Und mein Vater, der lebt noch, der ist natürlich schon alt
und der hat einen Magenprobleme.
Wie alt war ihrer Mutter?
Ja, die war 76, als sie gestorben ist.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, Geschwister habe ich nicht. Ich war alleine zu Hause.
Okay, und Sie sind zwei Highlights?
Nein, ich bin verwirrt, meine Frau ist verstorben.
Ach so, tut mir leid.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind natürlich schon groß, aber die sind beide noch zu Hause.
Sind Sie gesund?
Wir sind jetzt in der Ausbildung, der eine ist noch in der Schule.
Also die sind auch nicht auf dem Haus.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja, die sind gesund.
Okay, gut.
Und hör, ja, da war ich, wenn Sie von Beruf?
Ja, ich arbeite als Verabner in einem großen Unternehmen.
Ach so, warst du da?
Ja, arbeite da im Schichtdienst.
Man muss sich Frühdienst machen, man muss sich Spätdienst machen.
Und muss da viel telefonieren auch.
Okay, können Sie mir als Behle umwas machen, wie genau, aus Volken?
Ja, ich muss also gucken, wer ins Haus kommt.
Ich sitze im Eingangsbereich
und die Leute, die ins Haus kommen, melden sich bei mir an.
Und was weiß ich, die Mitarbeiter holen sich zum Teil ihre Schlüssel bei mir.
Oder wenn sie ein Auto ausleihen von der Firma,
dann müssen sie das bei mir quittierend,
dann gebe ich ihnen den Autoschlüssel und solche Sachen mache.
Und wie gesagt, Gäste müssen sich anmelden,
und sagen, wo sie hingehen in der Firma.
Und eben auch Anrufe entgegennehmen und weiterleiten.
Okay, verstehe ich schon.
Und Herr Jäger, ich habe alle wichtige Informationen montiert.
Haben Sie mal Fragen?
Oder mögen Sie noch etwas ergänzen?
Ja, eigentlich haben Sie ja schon viel gefragt.
Und ich habe Ihnen ja auch viel erzählt.
Ich wüsste Ihnen jetzt nicht.
Ich will natürlich schon wissen, was das ist
und was dahinter steckt und auch, was man dagegen tun kann.
Weil es so wirklich ja unangenehm ist.
Wie gesagt, ich möchte auch wieder ein bisschen fitter werden.
Ja, ich kann mir vorstellen.
Aber kann ich Ihnen auch etwas umsetzen?
Und leider nicht viel sein.
Aber meine Vermutung haben Sie wahrscheinlich
eine scheiße, eine scheiße Erkrankung.
Das heißt Akalasia.
Also jetzt erkläre ich Ihnen, was wir machen werden.
So heißt, weil ich sie eine törpärische Untersuchung
dann möchte ich Blut abnehmen.
Und dann werde ich ein paar weitere Untersuchungen
durchführen, zum Beispiel eine Röntgenbild.
Aber das ist eine besondere Röntgenuntersuchung.
Das heißt Breitschuluk.
Und das Ding war nicht so gut.
Ja, aber nicht so schlecht.
Wie funktioniert das?
Also bei dieser Untersuchung sehen wir, wie sie schlucken.
Und vor der Untersuchung schlucken wir eine Breit mit Barium.
Und das ist nicht gefährlich.
Und danach während dieser Untersuchung gucken wir
eine Schluckakt mit Röntgen.
Und was ist in dem Breit drin, dass man das sehen kann?
Also in manchen Menschen, diese Schluckakt kann stören.
Das merke ich, dass das stört bei mir.
Deswegen bin ich ja gekommen.
Wir müssen sicher sein.
Was für ein Breit schlucken wir da?
Ist das so wie grießfrei oder wie pudding?
Das ist wie ein Kontrastmittel.
Wie eine besondere Medikamente.
Wenn Sie da gucken, ist die Strahlenbelastung nicht groß?
Nicht groß.
Wie eine normale Röntgenuntersuchung.
Natürlich gibt es eine Ströllebelastung.
Aber ich kann sagen, dass es in Fluckhafen gibt,
dass es eine, die auch nicht groß ist.
Können wir uns das sehen?
Klar, man sieht, dass es nicht groß ist.
Genau, die Strahlenbelastung ist wie ein Geist.
Man sieht das nicht groß.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Schießen Sie los.
Ist Ihr Husten trocken oder mit Auswurf?
Der ist eher trocken.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Lymphknoten, Vergrößerung bemerkt?
Am Heißbereich oder Axelhöhe?
Ich habe das nicht bemerkt, aber ich habe das auch nicht gefühlt.
Danke.
Noch andere Fragen?
Könnten Sie sich mal sehen, ob ich schreibe und Sie die EHA stechend blendend?
Ja, das ist jetzt wieder schwer.
Einmal ist es ein Druckgefühl und es ist auch ein brennendes Gefühl.
Könnten Sie sich mal sehen, ob ich intensiv bin?
Nein, die Schmerzintensität.
Sie haben mich jetzt auch nach der Skala gefragt.
Die Schmerzen sind nicht unerträglich, sie sind nur lästig und stören beim Essen.
Ich würde sie unter der Mitte anordnen, bei 4 von 10.
Haben Sie Heißigkeit?
Minimal, eigentlich nicht so richtig doll, eher nicht.
Hatte Sie früher ähnliche oder magenbeschwörigen?
Nein, das ist neu für mich.
Ich habe noch Fragen gestellt.
Habt ihr in letzter Zeit abgenommen?
Hat sie gefragt?
Ich habe 3 kg abgenommen.
Eine Frage ist nicht gekommen, habe ich aber jetzt als Patient auch nicht von mir aus erzählt.
Das ist die Frage nach Besonderheiten beim Stuhlgang.
Könnten Sie Ihre Stuhl genau beschreiben?
Ich habe nicht gesehen, aber mir ist aufgefallen, dass die Farbe dunkel war.
Könnten Sie Ihre Haut oder Augenlässe seit Verfärbung bemerken?
Ich habe nicht gesehen und habe mich auch niemand angesprochen.
Wir sind erschöpft und Blasse geworden.
Blasse eigentlich, vielleicht ein bisschen, aber der Sommer ist ja auch vorbei.
Aber diese Information ist sehr wichtig.
Was haben Sie gehört, um die Stuhl zu machen?
Ich habe nicht gesehen, aber ich habe auch nicht gesehen.
Ich habe nicht gesehen, aber ich habe nicht gesehen.
Also guten Tag! Ich möchte Ihnen gerne den Patienten für Jäger vorstellen.
Er ist 50 Jahre alt und ein weiter 75 groß und 75 kg schwer.
Er steht sich bei uns vor auf dem Zeit eingebauten, bestehende und progresierende
Er ist schluckstuhl und er berichtete, dass diese Beschwerden im Laufe des Tages zuhause geworden sind.
Er steht, ich würde gerne statt Schluckstuhl und Dispoji.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass die Beschwerden mit dem Fettemarungs-Metzall und im Verlauf mit der Flüssigkeit aufstehen.
Am Anfang hat die Dispoji nur bestanden, wenn der feste Nahrung gegessen hat.
Jetzt besteht die Dispoji auch beim Trinken.
Ja.
Okay.
Er steht auf.
Auch.
Er steht auch.
Er hat 6
Ich habe immer 78 kg gewohnt.
Und jetzt die 75 kg.
Okay, okay.
Kommst du?
Ja.
Und begleitend bestehen Apetitlosigkeit,
Husten, Leichte, Aufstoßen und Dortbelennen.
Und Erschöpfung auch.
Ah, ja, okay.
Ja.
Und der Patient gibt es auch seitdem, was ihm eine Klosgefühl im Haustab.
Okay.
Ja.
Und die regerzätige Analyse war bis heute,
war bis auf Stuhlgangprobleme,
umaufweilig,
Melena,
ja,
Schutul bedrohtut Melena.
Okay, kann ich direkt Melena.
Okay.
Ja.
Und Anfuhrer-Präsenten sind seit 50 Jahren,
wir haben jetzt Meletus.
Ja, okay.
Ja, wir haben jetzt Meletus.
Ja, das bekannt.
Und der Patient gibt an,
dass ihm von ihm hausarzt,
eine Herzschrittmuschütterung festgestellt wurden.
Und der Arzt hat empfiehlen,
gegend diese Rhythmuschütterung,
eine Markumart.
Okay.
Und Anfuhr-Operationen
ist ein Abstand,
in dem Elimbogen Abstand für die Röpferin.
Und bei der Patientin sind gegend Diplof-Fernal,
so wie Greysapole aller Gerüchte.
Und dann sind die Elimbogen-Operationen
mit Erwärmung,
und dann sind die Regen-Pole
mit Konjunktivität.
Also Folgendemedikament,
Folgendemedikament,
mit Regen-Pole,
und ein genauen Ikantra, 50 Milligramm,
morgens und abends.
Also ja, und er ist Rauchherr.
Er rauchherr seit 20 Jahren,
ein Schachtsal pro Zag,
dass er 20 Peck jes,
und er trinkt eleganzlig Alkohol,
und bei der Familienanamese ergab sich folgendes. Die Mutter ist mit exo 70 an Kolonkarstinam
gestorben. Wir hatten wieder ein Verbindungsproblem. Wie ist die Mutter gestorben?
An Kolonkarstinam. Da vor zwei Leben noch und er leidet ein Magenprobleme.
Eine Geschwister und der Patient ist für die Witsel und habe zwei gesunde Kinder.
Und er ist Volkner. Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Meine Pfeil, ich habe nur sehr viele Leute, die Akkulasi haben.
Was könnte es sonst sein?
Vorher kamen auch die Alkranen im Veteran-Ödophagiskarstinam und Reflexkörnkalt.
Was war das erste, das Sie als Differente haben?
Ödophagiskarstinam.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Ulkosventripule.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ja, ich habe es nicht mehr gesehen.
Was machen Sie als Erstes?
Gastroskopie.
Was machen Sie als Allererstes?
Ich würde gerne als Körperlicher untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich denke, ich muss, ob es mein Mut ist.
Ob es ein Lymphknoten gibt.
Kann ich schuldig mit Heroid kontrollieren?
Was gucken Sie noch?
Dr. Gündnis hat nach der Augenfarbe gefragt.
Eine Gelbverparbung.
Blässehaut.
Was würde es für eine Gelbverparung sprechen?
Blässehaut?
Wenn der Blass ist.
Was ist die Verwaltung?
Ja, gut.
Was untersucht man noch?
Ich möchte noch eine Gastroskopie untersuchen.
Was machen Sie noch?
Sie haben den Patienten gesagt, dass sie Blut abnehmen wollen.
Ich muss sich die Hemoglobin-Märkte kontrollieren.
Vielleicht kann eine Entschlundung sein.
Dann kommt die Röntgen-Untersuchung.
Was machen Sie?
Ich habe den Reischluck.
Was könnte man als technische Untersuchung machen?
Ich möchte noch eine Röntgen-Untersuchung machen.
Was machen Sie noch?
Ich möchte noch eine Sonographie machen.
Ich habe etwas zu sagen.
Sie gucken wenig in die Kamera.
Sie sollten ihr Gegenüber, sowohl den Patienten als auch ihren Prüfer,
sagen.
Sie haben ein bisschen technische Probleme.
Sie wollen sich nicht mehr formulieren.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Betonung ist.
Es ist manchmal schwer zu verstehen.
Es ist manchmal schwer verständlich.
Sie haben mich nicht verstanden.
Ich habe mich von der Kränge gemacht.
Das war die Gewichtsverlust-Geschichte.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ich 20 Jahre alt bin.
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich 20 Jahre alt bin.
Was ist der Patient?
Er spricht deutlich dafür.
Ich habe noch eine Differenzialdiagose.
Da ist noch aufgeführt ein Zänkerdivertikel.
Das ist vielleicht noch so eine alternative.
Ich bin nicht ganz top zufrieden.
Sie gucken ihre Partner an.
Ich gucke immer in ihr Bild.
Sie kennen alle Fachbegriffe.
Sie machen kleine Grammatikfehler.
Sie sprechen nicht ganz ordentlich aus.
Das ist etwas, das sich nicht leicht zu beheben ist.
Sie haben ein bisschen Tempo rausgegeben.
Das ist besser verständlich.
Sie haben alles wiedergegeben.
Eine Sache haben Sie der Oberärztin nicht erzählt.
Sie haben beschrieben, dass die Spucke zusammenläuft.
Sie haben eine Hipper Salivation.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Fall kommt.
Sie sprechen nicht fast Sprache.
Das waren meine Punkte.